it's a boule keV com exclusive Liz Ready
Set Radio man shout out to the entire
phone volume kam man we're gonna let my
dude is he right take over the show man
number fun fighting for our yeah and we
got dizzy in the building and we also
got the guy who he was making fun of
earlier oh boy oh boy oh boy shot you yo
yo guys it's a good thing on it fun guys
I'm here back in Norwich yeah you know
me alright so we got Danzig the co-owner
of funk volume records what uh obviously
that sounds nothing like me nothing like
you ever had hey so name how did you
find Izzie right man um we gotta talk
closer to the mic by the way damn i know
you ain't used to be in in five about
right right uh well we don't mind all
the time okay that's kind of gonna for
and then you stumble for that I mean
funk volume was born on internet so we
in our fans are constantly shooting
videos at us yeah this we should sign
and look at this he was one of those
guys it's a couple years ago I saw the
video I think it was on the song called
somebody easy just um that was [__]
body or nobody somebody or nobody that
was the one that initially caught my art
and then I just happened to be
supporting another friend of mine who
was doing a contest locally in LA it was
like a RB portion and a hip-hop judge
the Vegas version of that I think yeah
make sure joint rise yeah it was that
competition but I was there to support
my homie and he won the honor be portion
ok so when he went back there was
another round the next round that's
where dizzy was that yeah cuz I guess he
won his his portion in in Vegas so
that's when I saw him perform live and
that's kind of what did it for me
because I saw people the way people
reacted to his music the way he was able
to capture the energy live I approached
him afterwards and introduce myself you
always tell the story kind of gave me
the cold shoulder hey hey you can't
blame them though man you know in this
world you never know what kind of random
at you
but they've been doing it for a minute
man yeah right all right so I understood
everybody you know I try to put my ego
to the side you know I just kept
following up with them you know it took
things slow because you know when you're
trying to ask somebody to the label is a
very very crucial decision true that
it's got to make sense on both ways so
just kept building the relationship kind
of filling them out and eventually we
just brought them out to Denver to show
them you know exactly what we do is you
go through you um you know and it just
made sense Denver's a big market for you
guys yeah yeah yeah it's like Denver is
like a big market for independent if I
was like technology point is push it's
too sure what's up so uh let's talk
about the start of the label your
brothers and swizz right Swizz your
brother rat he's signed to the label
right let me know when I get this wrong
he's like he came up with the high
school Hopsin yep okay and that's how
you guys knew each other right and you
had the business sense yepper say yeah
so about two thousand eight oh it just
happened to be perfect time because I
got laid off where were you working it I
was working for deloitte consulting to
imagine me consulting in Chicago that
sounds like some great corporate to
lawyer now I know why you're the guy you
they came to struggle a very corporate
man I went to I went to school route man
i got my MBA and was doing doing
management consulting in Chicago got
laid off and at that time I just kind of
figured out my my own lane and kind of
figure out what I wanted to do Swizz
approached me it was like Dame I don't
I'm not really happy at school you know
I think I want to do this music thing
and Hopsin he's not he was in the
ruthless situation at the time he was
like Hopsin kinda in the same same
situation that yourself and his project
you know can you come in and help us out
and I was like cool so initially I just
thought it was going to be kind of just
like a little project to help me for a
pass some time to when I find my next
job for him but as I started helping
them I saw the reaction from the fans
and I was a fan of the music as well it
wasn't just like all these guys are cool
it was like
these guys are my favorite rappers you
know and I was like man we can really
capitalize on this energy and just build
and just start going directly fans and
building that fan support is that the
secret um is the interaction with the
fans you think that you guys have kind
of like Ben Ben your key to like your
success because I feel like I honestly
like when Hopsin the first time I've
heard Hopsin was off the dribble tech
nine and beyond me and then I looked
them up and I that is it all is I mean
you think that's I kind of like the
secret to the successes I mean that's
desert 14 million heavy heavy fan
interaction heavy I mean we've been
online just talking to people replying
to people and have some I go cue to
people screams yeah well um I'm sure
he's been over some people's house but
skate I don't like every single before
before shows we've done ustream we
viewed every video chat platform
possible chatroulette footing
adultfriendfinder now I'm able we
whatever we try I mean because we're
independent we can do whatever we want
we trous try things and if they work and
we stick with them if they don't work
and we just try something else I gotta
ask you cuz i noticed that like dizzy
puts out so much material compared to
everybody else on the label right
specifically Hopsin and swiss gerrans
got a new I'm coming out but I was based
with artworks crazy for that by the way
feeling seen it is it's very it is
rather after um why why does I mean I
guess this might be a question for
Hobson but from your perspective um like
you said Hopsin doesn't put out that
much music why do you think that is or
why is that right well I mean every
artist has their own personal issues and
they also have their own creative
process so as running the label and I
try to develop an environment that suits
that individual artist so you can I mean
of course you located each person to
provide so it dizzy wants to put out how
the music that I'm gonna try to do
whatever I can to get that music the
most exposure as possible given the
resources we have but I made under label
you still you know gotta push them in
the drop down music oh for sure for sure
so it is I mean again you know sometimes
they take advantage of us being
independent you know so there's no I'm
gonna put off issue but I won't dad so
yeah so that's the thing
what we have to find a balance and as
we're growing you know where a young
label has withdrawn we need to figure
out what that balance is going to be and
people need to be more responsible and
accountable for what they're doing you
know but for the most part I want the
guys to feel free creating the music
that they want to create because that's
what they know what the fan they know
what their fans like and unless it's not
like you're gonna like really I mean
Swizz your roof is your brother man
that's another L okay go Hey look bro I
don't want to put on out right now okay
right what are you gonna do when you're
gonna kick your brother off the label we
know that I dizzy let's talk about your
work ethic bro like we're saying you can
put out a bunch of music you put out
lots of visuals yeah um do you feel like
you're you know many are you ever scared
over saturate the phone volume fan base
nah nah I mean funk volume I got with
funk volume did so because each artist
can be their own right you know the
saying I can't slow down for nobody else
like I'm young and I'm just ready like I
prep myself for all of this like so my
work ethic to everybody is I low but for
me is just natural I'm like how many
songs you're sitting on right now like
I'm sitting on a grip of songs just like
I'm finished songs lipika labs like I
did super collapse like over the last
year just like the locals inches so I
just go hard I just like making music I
love right and I love doing it I'm
saying now then now that you're on the
double XL cover how many calls have you
gotten from random scallywag Vegas
rappers a lot about like remember back
in the day yeah when I saw you at the
meadows mall umbrella I need a managing
you know this joint man exactly
everybody here exactly that's exactly
what's happened that's what's happening
right here everybody just want me on
there you don't want me to hop on these
stuff and just like trying to throw like
little hints out there like little small
things that happen that guy oh my god
has anyone called you Hollywood you know
nobody caught me Hollywood yeah I'm sure
it's gonna come but yeah nobody probably
saying it behind your back yeah yeah I'm
sure I'm sure somebody saying it i be
chillin though everybody not a who was a
rapper you put out a video I remember
watching a couple years ago he was
sitting like on a washer dissing
somebody oh yeah I had a man is crazy
because I started recording in his
studio when I first moved back to Vegas
first okay and then uh throughout the
city when I first started doing shows
with like no wait I wasn't gonna show
the phone volume and I was doing shows
by myself just like I was just kind of
getting out there i think i did like 106
and park yeah and i'm just doing a few
things and uh he has seen some
interviews and I guess he felt like I
wasn't giving him no love that's the
worst and I'm like I didn't really know
like what he meant like about somebody
else yeah cuz I mean if somebody asks me
the question about it like you know I
definitely bring his name up but I mean
he just was recording this stuff like he
wanted some extra love that I ain't had
for him so we basically he started going
around the city just popping his gums
like and i'll let it go at first and now
he's working but the city pumped it up
that's what made me mad this is eddie
twitter the my own city was acting like
you know he really got at me okay so I'm
like okay oh my are you serious Danzo I
was like I'm not to bite his head off oh
damn we're talking earlier man I feel
like very soon especially I think dizzy
is really got star potential like like
as far as his the music he makes mm-hmm
can transcend like radio all that [__]
you want him saying right um and
independently that's kind of like
sometimes you know people are
independent for
because they don't make music that you
know that might not you know transcend
to a wider wider audience i think busy
does so um do you think the time will
come or you guys have like your Chi te
moment you guys you know link up really
major and kind of kind of fun with that
little steps are you guys even
interested in doing anything possible
right no I don't think so I don't I me
not right now you know my focus is on
building the right relationships is to
take any artist to the next we look to
the next level and one of those being
radio and I feel like we're starting to
put the pieces together to be able to
accomplish that on her own no label has
a protest with anything that makes sense
right again I'm trying to cater to each
individual artist though so we would
never move from volume to a label
however if it made sense for an artist
for individual artists and they put the
right offer on the table and the artist
wanted to do that then I would support
it nope